معنا الان من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره نزار
بقداوي نزار اهلا بك اذا هل سجل اي تقدم
على الصعيد هذه التسويه تسويه الخلافات
بين الفرقه
سفيان يعني هذه التحركات صراحه قبل ان تصل
الى هذه المرحله المتقدمه
سبقت بتحركات ماكوكيه للفاعلين الدوليين
هنا في الخرطوم
كان الاليه
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه الايكات
الى جانب ايضا ضعيه الدوليه المتمثله في
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
والامارات والمملكه العربيه السعوديه قبل
اكثر من اربع ساعات كان هنالك اجتماع ضمه
الموقعين على الاتفاق الايطالي من
المدنيين هذا الاجتماع خلصت الى ان هنالك
جاهزيه من قبل القوه المدنيه
للتوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي صباح السبت
لكنه في المقابل طالبوا العسكريين في
السلطه بتحديد موقف واضح ورسمي من هذا
الاعلان هل هم على اتم الجاهزيه ام هنالك
تردد ام هنالك حاجه الى مزيد من النقاش
انا الان اتحدث سفيان وقد دخل ممثلون
القوى المدنيه في اجتماع
مضى هذا الاتمام على اكثر من نصف ساعه يضم
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي عبد الفتاح
البرهان القائد العام للجيش السوداني الى
جانب محمد حمدان دقلو حماتي قائد قوات
الدعم السريع النائب رئيس المجلس السيادي
هذا
بمكان لانه سيحدد موقف العسكريين بعد ان
حسم المدنيون موقفهم وقالوا بانهم على اتم
الجاهزيه للتوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي
صباح السبت عليه ان نتوقع ان يخرج بيان من
قبل العسكريين يوضح هل سيوقعون على
الاتفاق الايطالي يوم السبت مفهوم في حاجه
الى مزيد من التشاور مع اللجان الفنيه
المعنيه بقضيه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وعليه هذا الاجتماع سيتحدد عبره الموقف
الرسمي والنهائي من الميقات الزمني
للاتفاق الايطالي كذا لم يوضح هذا الموقف
هذا يعني بصوره عمليه انا الاتفاق الذي
يوقع صباح السبت وانما هنالك ميقات الزمني
جديد سيحدد لاحقا عبر اعلان رسمي سواء من
العسكريين او من المدنيين
نزاره بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك